there was a rich man who was dressed in
purple and fine linen and lived in
luxury every
day at his gate was laid a beggar named
Lazarus covered with s sores I can't
read and longing to eat what fell from
the rich man's
table now before we move on let me
explain what Jesus is gonna teach now
guys I'm gonna also do this as a
preaching Expos preaching where we're
going to learn some life lessons I'm
going to kill several Birds one stone
the rich man is living lavishly He
enjoying life to the fullest the rich
man is at the gate which means that the
rich man is aware of his condition how
do we know because number one the rich
man would have servants and he himself
would have would exit the gate enter the
gate because he's not going to stay home
all day right so he goes out comes in he
sees this man full of sores physically
in pain hungry and he doesn't show him a
lick of Mercy
right right right right oh I thought you
Wasing you too you're gonna have to
answer specifically the people there are
not going to okay so right so he does
show Mercy right right right now watch
here keep reading
okay the time came well it's not that
part even the dogs came and licked his
sores this is significant okay now here
the word for dogs is the word used
Elsewhere for RAB dog a dog that is out
of control a dog that is Rabbi and needs
to be put down it's the word that Jesus
uses in Matthew 7:6 where he says do not
give what is sacred to dogs or give cast
Pearls Before Swine right right it's the
same word used by John in Revelation
22:15 where he says outside of the
kingdom are the dogs it's the same word
used by Paul when he describes the
judaizers in Philippians 3:2 he calls
them dogs it's the same word this word
is used for an
unregenerate reprobate vile sinner who
handed over to judgment okay right so
notice these Raby dogs who are merciless
are showing mercy and compassion to
Lazarus something the rich man doesn't
do so what does that tell you about the
rich man he's even
worse yeah now continue now you read to
21 read now
2223 the time came when the beggar died
and the angels carried him to Abraham's
side that's Abraham's bosom right now
yes now what did they carry it says
Lazarus died so what were they carrying
what did the Angels carry him we say
carry him him he died what him what part
of him his soul you got it you don't
carry the body the body dies decays the
tyot returns to the dust but they're
carrying him meaning his inner person
his soul right right right right so
notice the soul can be carried by Spirit
creatures and and the Soul has a shape
of some kind by which you are still
recognizable and it's still you and you
can be distinguished from another Soul
you caught it right okay so now read the
next part keep reading to 23 the rich
man also died and was buried so what was
buried what do you bury when a man dies
his body so when the rich man died cuz
he unlike Lazarus he has family they
buried him but what do you bury the body
but then notice what it says read it 23
all the way in Hades where he was in
torment he looked up and saw Abraham far
away with where is
he in where is he in Tor
where looks
like but what does it say what's the
word Hades he's in Hades so when the
rich man was buried he himself was in
Hades in
torment so what part of him is in Hades
because if he's buried which part of him
was
buried well his body was buried so what
part of him was in Hades his soul ah but
did you see that you are your soul you
are your body because it didn't say his
body was buried his soul was there go he
was buried and he was in Hades right so
it's connected the Bible often will call
your body you and off will call your
soul you so oh we buried Protestant oh
but Pro is in heaven but I thought you
buried him yeah because his body was
buried his soul is in heaven so I can
speak of his body as him and his soul as
him so he was buried but he's in Hades I
the body was buried but the soul is in
Hades but it's experiencing torment so
the number one even in the realm of the
Dead when our bodies return to the dust
until the resurrection we continue to
experience sensation in emotions we
still have sensation feelings and
emotions CU he's feeling
torment number two we have awareness
because if you can feel torment that
means you're aware and we recognize one
another because in that verse it says a
far off so he knew they're a great
distance away so in the realm of the
dead or the spirit realm it is a
dimension that has space and place
because you travel oh he's over there
right so there's distance so there's
space there's place
and he recognizes Abraham and Lazarus by
his side right right how can you know
Abraham and Lazarus and distinguish
Abraham from Lazarus If Abraham and
Lazarus though without physical bodies
still as Souls they have a solish
spiritual form and shape by which you
can distinguish
them wow you caught it yeah that's wow
but another important before you ask me
a question important lesson you learn
from this did the Lord ever give Lazarus
relief in this
world what do you mean by that well you
read it what was Lazarus begging
for oh he was begging for the rich man's
food at the table and how about his
physical condition was he sick did he
have sores did the Lord ever give him
relief in this
world I want to say no cuz I didn't see
it no of course not that's the point he
died in that state now La the rich man
living a hedonistic lifestyle partying
up you know gluttony sexual perversion
enjoying life to the fullest did God
ever punish him in this world no another
lesson you learn my brothers and sisters
in Christ contrary to what some teachers
will teach you God doesn't always come
to save and vindicate the righteous in
this life nor does he always come and
condemn the wicked in this life God may
allow the wicked to prosper till they
die like you Hefner and allow Christians
to suffer and even be killed because
your Vindication comes in the day of
judgment and their destruction takes
place in the afterlife at the day of
judgment yeah I actually seen you do a
show on this it was in the Psalms but I
don't remember what chapter yeah but it
was no no no it wasn't the Psalms it was
somebody who blasphemed the Lord it was
Jeremiah Jeremiah had Blas the Lord he
was miserable right and but now go ahead
finish Point sorry go yeah what I was
saying I was saying that um he was
asking why hasn't the Lord come to you
know yeah why didn't you he I'm
miserable like hell my life was better
before I got to know you and yeah
because the Lord didn't say like these
prosperity preachers hey give something
you get 10,000 no more Camp you gonna
get Mansion all right now now watch the
Vindication and the role reversal
remember in this world Lazarus was at
the mercy of the rich man right right
now to answer your question where do the
D go to Hades to show to be tormented
right there you see
it Luke 1623 well I was asking for right
now after Jesus died well yeah that
didn't change oh it's still the exact
same she old Hades is where they
go yep that's in Revelation 2 20: 11:15
what did it say it said the dead gave up
the dead that was in it and Hades gave
up the dead that was in it right
remember that yeah so disbelievers are
still in Hades and in torment the
Believers are in Heavenly Paradise
meaning they're in this heavenly
dimension of paradise where they're at
Bliss and peace and they are flooded and
basking in the presence of our God the
Father the Son the Lord Jesus the Holy
Spirit beholding the Angels now notice
the role reversal though remember in
this world Lazarus what do at the mercy
of the rich man right right watch the r
reversal so when he sees Abraham and
Lazarus a far off notice 24 and 25 24
and
25 so he called to Him Father Abraham
have pity on me he's begging for
mercy and send Lazarus to dip the tip of
his finger in water now he's dependent
on Lazarus to show him mercy and
comfort right whereas in this world
Lazarus was dependent on the rich man to
comfort him now the rich man needs
Lazarus to comfort
him you caught it yeah
Lazarus to dip his finger in this water
right right and my tongue to experience
the coolness temporarily because I'm in
agony in the Flames read 24
so he called to Him Father Abraham have
pity on me and send Lazarus to dip the
tip of his finger in water and cool my
tongue because I am in agony in this
fire now notice however this spiritual
Dimension exists it is different from
the physical universe but similar enough
to it because even in this place you
have water even in this place he can see
that Lazarus has
fingers even in this place he can speak
of his tongue being
tormented so the spiritual Dimension is
a dimension that is unlike the Earth but
similar enough to it that there's
continuity it's not the same but similar
you caught it yeah okay so he's now at
the mercy of Lazarus like Lazarus at the
mercy at him so notice what Abraham says
to Him Luke
1625 this is the actually the good part
I ain't going to lie cuz at the end did
something that he says that hits home
but um but Abraham replied son remember
that in your lifetime you received your
good things while Lazarus received bad
things but now he has
comforted here and you are in agony and
besides yes don't go to 26 yet here is
the ultimate Vindication and judgment
Lazarus suffered miserably till he died
now he's in Everlasting peace rest no
more pain no more suffering you enjoyed
your pleasures you enjoyed like to the
fullest on earth now is time for you to
experience punishment and suffering That
Never
Ends C that you see that now yeah okay
so but now notice another thing Abraham
knows this is one of his descendants son
you're my son Father Abraham but notice
Abraham has no pity for him do you know
why he has no pity for him because he
didn't have pity for Lazarus that's why
Jesus says if you don't show Mercy you
will not be shown
Mercy if you
don't Grant mercy and be merciful you
will not be given mercy and in heaven
none will be merciful to you if you
don't forgive you won't be forgiven this
is what Jesus is telling you rather you
have friends in heaven who will show you
mercy and pity you and love you but the
way you make friends in heaven is how
you be gave on Earth because if you show
no pity or Mercy or compassion in this
life those in heaven will show you no
mercy no pity no compassion if you don't
give Mercy you shall receive none in the
Life to Come amen then he says in 26 and
by the way do you see that Abraham knew
how they lived on Earth yeah they
hedonistic yeah he life tells you that
it is a lie and it's not biblical to
assume that those in
are not aware of people's lives and
conditions on Earth Abraham had been
dead physically but he knew this is how
you live this is how he
lived so you mean like they so
like if I was to run somebody over with
a car right now right God forbid it
depends Abraham Abraham knows I did that
it it depends God will reveal whatever
he wants the Saints in heaven to know
and it's his prerogative how much he
reveals how much he keeps so it's not
clear that he Reveals All Things to them
but we know he does reveal some things
of not most things to them that's the
point right right right that's the point
I'm not saying he has to reveal
everything to them right but again the
point is does God reveal things to
people in heaven and make them aware
absolutely here it is Abraham in fact
I'm going to show you how much Abraham
knew even though he wasn't on earth now
remember Moses and the prophets came
long after Abraham right right like a
thousand years Abraham was
dead about 400 years before Mo Moses
came and the prophetic writings the
writings of Moses and the prophets came
centuries after his death right right
okay keep that in mind now read
26 all the way to 29 26 29 we're almost
done with
this and besides all this between us
and you a great Chasm has been set in
place so that those who want to go from
here to you cannot nor can anyone cross
over from there to us now this is not
Purgatory by the way because Purgatory
as understood historically is not the
place of the damn it's a place of
Believers where it's purifying fire to
purge them to cleanse them on the merits
of Jesus Christ to enter Heaven these
people that are in Hades tormented
they're damned they're not coming out
it's over yeah that's you're done
because what did he say right you
enjoyed life now you're receiving
punishment now it's time for punishment
you're not forgiven because what did God
say if you don't forgive you won't be
forgiven if you don't show Mercy you
won't be shown mercy so he died in an
unmerciful unforgiving state so he's cut
off he's severed this is Everlasting
destruction so those are there they're
not coming out those in glory they won't
so that's why when people tell me Well
if Believers will be judged on the day
of judgment on the day when Christ comes
but they're already in heaven why will
they be judged like here Abraham and
Lazarus are already in a state of peace
and Abraham says he and I are in peace
and Bliss Comfort no more pain no more
suffering and we'll never end up where
you're at Our Fate is Seal it's
Everlasting security and peace and
comfort so then why will they go before
the Lord in judgment because that's
where God will then reward them
for what they've done in the body and
assign to them their ranks and
positions amen you got it yeah okay but
now it gets better so what does it say
keep reading man come on it said it gets
better it does get better though it does
yes it does he answered then I beg you
father send Lazarus to my family for I
have five brothers let him warn them so
that they will not also come to this
place
torment Abraham repli notice it's a
place of Torment right all right so the
Damned are tormented right and he's
afraid his brothers will die in the same
condition as him and end up in torment
with him right right but did you notice
that the the rich man is
still bossing people around and
commanding people and giving orders he
first tells Abraham send
Lazarus and now he says Sone someone
here to my brothers so it's all about
him again right
how they can benefit him how they can
serve him and he's the one demanding or
ordering what he wants them to do for
him send Lazarus to me so he's telling
Abraham send him to me and I Abraham
send them please in other words it's all
about him it's all about him and his own
you catch the selfish attitude so so
quick question I've seen
apologist like Frank Turk say that when
people like go to hell they won't repent
anyways would this be kind of like a
proof text of what he said that even
when you go to hell you still can't even
say you're sorry or yes it is because
it's no repentance no I am sorry for
what I've done I feel disappointed
Father Abraham that I proved faithless
to God and that I didn't love my fellow
brother there is no repentance it's
still
selfishness right right okay now what
what does Abraham tell him because he's
saying send someone here from the realm
of the Dead to appear on Earth to
convince them not to come here that this
place is real avoid it now what does he
say Abraham replied they have Moses and
the prophets let them listen to them no
Father Abraham he said oh he's telling
them no but if someone from the dead go
to them they will repent he said to them
if they do not listen Moses and the
prophets they will not be convinced even
if someone rises from the dead that's
the biggest one right here now let me
ask you something how did Abraham know
that on Earth currently at that moment
the Jews had the Old Testament
scriptures they had Moses and the
prophets I guess God told him so you
mean God made known to Abraham prophets
came after him that wrote scriptures
that are preserved and that people have
access to because notice what he says to
him your brothers have Moses and the
prophets well Moses wasn't there he had
died the prophets were dead so it means
they have the writings of Moses and the
prophets right Moses and the prophets if
they believe Moses and the prophets then
they have enough there to warn them
about God's Wrath and that they need to
repent they go no that's not enough
because I had them too didn't do
anything for me well that's why you're a
rotten
scoundrel he goes well if they don't
believe Moses in the prophets then they
won't even believe even if someone rises
from them now Jesus is talking and he's
speak speaking in
irony you Jews don't really believe
Moses and the prophets because if you
really believe Moses and the prophets
You' believe me and turn to me but
because you don't believe them you won't
even believe when I rise from the dead
and leave the tomb empty but try to
explain it
away Jesus is using
this exchange and experience that took
place in the afterlife and I believe
it's an actual experience that took
place that Jesus would know because he's
God to illustrate a greater spiritual
truth and what was the point that Jesus
was
illustrating if you don't truly
understand and believe what Moses and
the prophets have written about
salvation the coming Messiah then you're
gonna miss miss who I am right you're
gonna miss me meaning not miss me all
like oh you're not going to figure out
who I am and even when I leave the tomb
empty you still won't be convinced but
explain it away cuz you have not
believed meaning understood and
appreciated what the prophets had said
Messiah would do that he would die and
rise from the dead so that when the tomb
is empty because you don't believe what
they've said about Messiah or understood
what they said about Messiah you won't
believe the tomb is empty because you
won't believe I'm the one right and
you're gonna explain exactly what they
did right yeah they did they tried to
explain the way oh yeah the boss stole
the body okay all right